hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcasts rapid tests to decipher
microbiome function in health and
disease I am Brenda Kelly king of
labyrinth and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we're delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
kaya gem infectious diseases are a
leading cause of death worldwide and a
better understanding of the lives of
microorganisms and their interactions
with host cells and animals is critical
to the prevention of illness and
fatalities qiagen understands your
specific research challenges and offers
you innovative solutions that cover
every single step along this journey not
just technologies with bridges from
samples to insights sample to incite us
qiagen offers you the industry's most
reliable sample technologies because
samples matter to your success our top
quality essays and panels enable you to
accurately analyze and identify diseases
and genetic variations our
bioinformatics software and curated
knowledge bases transform your raw data
into relevant actionable findings sample
to incite the insights you gain they
lead to one small step for a giant leap
forward for science and health care
partnering with kaya gen your work can
make a difference the more information
please visit wwe.com before we begin we
have a few announcements this webcast is
designed to be interactive and we
encourage you to ask questions during
the event you can submit questions by
typing them in a Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button in the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to answer
as many of your questions as we can you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
the support button at the top right of
your presentation window or submit your
problem through the green Q&A button
lower left would now like to introduce
today's speaker
anisha cartia anisha is a molecular
biologist who is responsible for sample
to incite solutions that are provided
through kiya Jen's microbial DNA qpcr
portfolio of products anisha's research
was focused on discovering biomarkers in
liquid solutions prior to her current
role as an associate floral product
manager she worked as a biological
research content specialist in which she
helped her customers plan their projects
and the right products in Pijin I will
now turn it over to Anisha for her
presentation Thank You Brenda Oh for the
kind introduction are today I will be
talking about a rapid test to decipher
microbiome function in health and
diseases first I would like to introduce
you kai jian we have the new mission
statement which is we have leaders and
sample inside solutions and when I say
example to insight that means are we
have all the solutions for sample
technologies for extraction on of any
complex samples that you are dealing
with in your research along with the
acid technologies that is once you have
extracted your cell phones you would
like to experiment it research it using
our essays and arrays and chitin
provides really good solution for acid
technologies moving forward we had all
the bioinformatics solution that
provides the right inside to the
researchers along with the complete
automation system so we provide the
complete workflow from sample to insight
and help researchers to answer the
complete biological question that they
are looking for instead of just giving
them part solution in terms of
products for today's agenda I would be
talking about introduction to micro
biome technologies that unlock the
metagenomics that would also include the
knee and also all the available methods
for Lapid technologies and then I will
be talking about population studies and
disease associations with these
metagenomics and microbiome and how do
we really design assays for the
microbiome moving forward will be the
solutions for identification or
profiling from chitin itself and then I
will be summarizing the complete webinar
along with opening the platform for
questions so what does our cellular
composition of the organism made of it
has been estimated the number of
microbial cells that live in and on a
human body cells are outnumbered human
cells are outnumbered by a factor of 10
that means the microbiota is really
important to be under to understand or
to be understood for any of the research
for any of the infectious disease for
any of the metagenomic diseases sorry
normal normal nature use in the industry
our microbiota that are the microbes
that live in a specific location example
the human body guard soil etc or
metagenomics that is the study of the
collection of genomes derived from a
specific sample or community then we
have microbes or microbial species that
are microscopic organisms that can be
either single or multi cellular so how
why is the complexity and function of
this genomic content so important as we
all know with the function of the
microbiome enables individual survival
so each organism has developed the
generated content for its own survival
in a specific in
we have different kind of metabolic sins
going on inside her body it has
carbohydrate metabolism lipid metabolism
nucleotide amino acids etc and somehow
all of these metabolisms are involved
with different microbes and different
microbial organisms these metabolism
turn to a local nutrient sources and
also the two other factors the valence
factors that are there for stabilizing
the colonization and also i divided
resistant genes to metabolize these
toxins but in a nutshell since the
microbes play such an important part in
these metabolisms it does play an
important part in other diseases
infectious diseases etc so it is very
important for researchers to really
understand what how the metagenomics or
how the microbial content or how the
microbes or which microbes are really
affecting and and getting associated
with different conditions in a specific
disease area so now I will be talking
about the technologies that along the
metagenomics the cutting methods for
microbial analysis of which are
available in with the researchers and
with the industry our culture method
micro away next generation sequencing
multi that is your mass spec and the
qpcr that is target dependent 16s rrna
or gene dependent now the culture which
has been the gold standard method and
has been the most cost effective method
and used worldwide within the industries
and with the researchers having their
forever but it has some limitations to
itself when we say about limitations we
talk in terms of time consuming it
involves multiple steps and it takes
around five to seven days it cannot
identify all the pathogens at the same
time and also the culture conditions are
different for each pathogen so you have
to grow different cultures to go
different pathogens
different conditions it also involves
the expenditure in terms of risk and
logistics require expensive biologic
microbiological training and also
there's a lot of waste that is generated
so with the industry and with the
clinical pathology it has been come to a
new that the rapid detection methods are
really important for these microbial
detection and quantification with this
two methods came into existence which
are tagged as rapid metals the first one
is the NGS for the whole genome
sequencing or 16s rrna sequencing
whereas NGS is really good for both
discovery and comparative analysis it
still has some challenges to itself such
as technical challenges it has high cost
it is not amenable tilting testing at
this time it has complex data output so
it's really difficult to make
understanding of what kind of output
data you have received and how to
analyze it and it's still two days work
through it has definitely reduced from
seven days to two days but still along
the procedure for a clinical routine
testing or for industries for applied
testing etc then the other method that
came into existence is real-time PCR
which is specific it only detects the
target sequence with a sensitive it can
detect low copy numbers it is very rapid
it is easy to set up and the detection
is under 90 minutes and also it can be
standardized so we so a customer or a
researcher is able to create automated
protocols and also generate stable
chemical designs so if you look at the
16 of the qpcr technology in general the
16s rrna region of the bacteria plays a
really important part not only in the
qpcr technology but also in the NGS and
other rapid testing methods with the
help of the sixth
s rrna written specifically in bacteria
one can identify and determined 95%
genus level ninety-seven percent species
level and ninety-nine percent strain
level of the bacteria so our bacterial
16s rrna region is made up of conserved
region and variable regions and these
variable regions in the in the base pair
of 12 1500 will determine what species
of the bacteria this bacteria really is
so the 16s rrna gene has become the most
important and most of the CDC our
technology and NGS has been done around
this region of course it would really
for different species such as fungi
viruses etc so how did we all get
started the first report of the
composition of the urine body site was
done by inner edge where it was
published in science and said it talked
about metagenomic analysis of the human
distal gut microbiome and then all the
researchers thought that if you can do
one can we do that on that's where a lot
of interest and microbiome metagenomic
studies came into existence and Lord
grants started happening excuse me an
international effort to catalog the
microbiome came into existence hmp mehta
a chai tea sooo silly international
human microbiome consortium etc they all
can you chill together to put an
international effort to catalog this
micro-bio
the first nih human microbiome project
was started in 2008 where mah came
together to profile 5 body sites nasal
mount skin gastrointestinal system and
urogenital and a lot of comparative
studies between the individuals were
conducted in terms of how we pay for
healthy people versus disease patients
treated samples versus untreated samples
twin studies difference between the tied
between the tools individuals are two
animals and all of this helped us to
create a database in fact from hydrogen
we have created and we have associated
microbes along with these body sites and
if you would like to get a list please
feel free to ask after the webinar and
then there's the NIH funding across the
Institute's of microbiome related
studies increased from 2008 drastically
to 2000 drastically to 2013 if you see
these if we see these beads with the
yellow sign which is increased
drastically to 2013 and this shows the
number of funding projects that increase
and also the paintings and the research
papers the publications around the
microbiome increased drastically from
2008 to 2013 and it's trend is
increasing now another really important
area of interest and research are the 23
car the antibiotic resistant genes and
the antibiotic resistant genes has has
been seen to create around 23,000 beds
of in the US and z GC estimated that the
cause sickness in 2 million people and
twenty-three thousand deaths per year
and also in march 2015 obama
administration
national act line to combine this
particular antibiotic resistant bacteria
and also in June on jun 20 second or
2015 the Washington are the National
Cattlemen's Association participated in
White House forum on antibiotic
stewardship so a lot of researchers have
got into the action to really read and
also make associations about these
antibiotic resistant genes two different
diseases another area which is a lot
interest to researchers as well as
applied testing companies are the food
industry and microbes from 1837 with
where we first actually analyze the role
of east and alcoholic fermentation it's
been the trend to use the microbes in a
control condition to form a or to
produce radius food products pad
increase and also there are around 3,500
delish middle fermented food in the
world if we use these microbes in a
controlled manner then we are able to
produce different food items but at the
same time if it is not controlled or if
another stream or another species of
microbe has grown it can lead to a lot
of of products which are not very
important or necessary for the food and
good spot and grants while the fool
through the data from the agriculture
and food contamination scenario RCTC
estimated that each year roughly one in
six Americans of all the 8 million
people get sick that is around 12 8,000
people are hospitalized and 3000 die of
food one diseases and this is all
because of some microbial infection so
it is really important for the food
industry to QC their products and to
understand these microbes infect
so for this to help industry on to the
criminal diagnostic market it is really
important for researchers to come up
with this comparative studies with the
database or to understand and to make
associations with these up with some
particular microbes to the different of
diseases infections QC criterias etc so
some of the popular applications that
have been going on in the industry for
example some of the hospitals are
detecting antibiotic resistant genes and
Mirza emphasises of the newborn babies
to associate bad to certain diseases and
also some of the Institute's are testing
individual patients before and after
their visit to the other countries to
really learn about the antibiotic
resistant genes change when they are
traveling there's another prevalent
studies study that is going on are
around the hospital acquired infection
that a hospital by keeping records of
customers leaving the hospital regarding
if they really acquired the infection in
the hospital so then do the antibiotic
resistance of QC right when the
customers right when the patient is
leaving and also a lot of universities
and hospitals are detecting these
antibiotic resistant genes to prevent
the surface contamination and hospitals
by seeing different methods what is the
best way to clean the a year on the
hospitals then another one is to test
antibiotic resistant genes in women's
how to swab samples and various other
diseases if we look at the health care
and the women have industry applications
that a lot of researchers are looking
into respiratory infection in this tiny
infection metagenomic diseases around
the stool samples the missile samples to
come up associations with certain
diseases and certain microbes together
and also there is a need for routine
testing and women
from the cervical from cervical samples
or to test for bacterial vaginosis in
the food and the great application if we
look at then all the duties of the food
processing companies the animal food
baby food etc the need to detect all
these pathogens for the QC criteria so
there's lot of demand and lot of
research that has needed to associate
certain microbial species with certain
function so that it can be implemented
in the clinical diagnostic market and
also in the applied testing market of
just to get a better QC and better
health control so I would be now talking
about some of the focus metagenomic
applications whatever what are the
examples of the next wave of the
microbiome experiment these are the
examples that are chitin conducted with
some of the collaborators and we perform
the collaborators used a hydrogen PCR
race that is all the microbial detection
acids on a plane and came up with a
certain experimental of microbiome
experiments and I will be going ahead
and showing some of the data over here
so the first experiment we wanted to
learn it's a small epidemiology study
which talks about antibiotic resistant
genes in the human gut so we didn't
wanted to understand is this antibiotic
genes is in our food supply or not so
what we chilled we took the samples from
the sea wage from the crops from the
need and from the stool samples of the
human beings to really understand if
these antibiotic resistant genes are
getting transferred in the food supply
and now one can think how are we
thinking that it might be transferring
in the food supply so with Yuri the
hypothesis begins
when or if you take the antibiotic
resistant samples if you take the DNA
samples from this image it can be
transferred to the foot of to the crops
where the crops are grown and those
semen samples are used as fertilizers
and those crops can be hence eaten by
the by the cattle and the cattle is
usually used to get work mode and mean
which the humans would eat or they would
eat the crops so if we have a source of
antibiotic resistant genes in the
signature anywhere in the supply chain
that it gets turned around so this is
the complete hypothesis of the story of
the experiment where the researchers
they took all the four samples and they
tested it on a 96-well plate of a qpcr
where each well is one of the antibiotic
resistant genes so this kpc is what I
divided resistant gene which is present
in one well so in the same manner this
96-well plate or you can see of the you
have 84 antibiotic resistant gene still
the OPR till the OPR J and then rest of
them are the pan bacteria ntpc which are
present for the control of the plate
then the researchers follow these simple
steps that is the extracted with DNA
from various samples from various
metagenomic complex samples and using
the chi ching hai and kit tool and then
they put the sample mix it with the qpcr
master mix i reported and each well in
the plate and then perform the act and
then run it on the real-time pcr machine
once they run it on the real-time pcr
machine two kinds of experiments are
possible dig the profiling and I didn't
patient for this particular experiment
they perform identification that is Qin
known if a particular antibiotic
resistant gene is present in the sample
or not so here are some of the data or
the first table over here shows the
semen samples the first data over here
shows the single sample over the DNA was
extracted from this ad when it was run
on that VCR plate including 96
antibiotic resistant genes we found out
that most of these genes right over here
with the resistant classification just
specified right next to it hi positive
antibiotic resistant presence and then
we also perform the samples from this
tool from the from the stool of the
human beings living around the same area
and it was it went to the same
experiment process of testing it on the
antibiotic resistant gene panel and the
researchers are found out that the arm
be mess a and tech a were found in all
or most of the stool samples tested
showing that they may be highly
prevalent in the cart so these
antibiotic resistant genes have been
reported to be isolated from bacterial
strains originating from food suggesting
a possible source of the region and also
there were 14 antibiotic resistant genes
from different resistance classification
that were present in the metagenomic
sample the verification protocol
determined that these genes were present
in receive it samples as well just to
confirm are we further did a study where
we took three samples beef chicken and
poor and another three set of samples
from vegetables that were carried
lettuce and potato it will they ran or
the DNA extracted from there we ran on
the same antibiotic resistance panel and
the results were correlated with the sea
example and masoud samples and excuse me
and there was another interesting result
that the collaborators and chitin saw
were the antibiotic resistance genes
that were there in the meat samples were
similar and also read genes that were
there in the vegetables were mostly
similar and they were all correlating
back to the data from C wedge and also
with the stool samples now this is a
small study that was conducted and the
study is not leaking over and we are
doing a full grown study or with a
collaborator and similarly this is just
an example but you can take the array
and use it for your particular study for
different applications now the next
study was done or to screen the sample
of specific pathogen resistant genes or
valence factors in this study or what we
did we took the samples from the women
or cervical area and the soft samples
were taken and they were divested
similar of protocol and it they will run
on the bacterial vaginosis panel from
kyden so again each of these welds over
here are the specific bacteria related
to bacterial vaginosis and oh here we
have we can test two samples per well
latter's we have 48 associated 48
associated bacterial vaginosis bacteria
along with the positive controls so if
we see then all of these are so here are
the are the bacterial vaginosis bacteria
and the last column the last few wells
over here are are the controls are from
hydrogen so this is the plate for the
bacterial vaginosis and then these
samples were taken from the swab and
were extracted using the Cayenne mini
kit and they were mixed with the masa
mix to put it on pcr played and ran on
the real time pcr machine again to do
the identification experiment so the
results from here showed the bacterial
vaginosis negative sample showed
negative for all the bacteria which were
negative for bacterial vaginosis and
then other samples which were candida
positive gb positive and take enormous
trichomonas positive were showed
positive for candida GD and trichomonas
respectively which shows the efficiency
of the array and also different kind of
samples were then tested after that then
another state of study that was done to
profile the changes in vaginal flora
during the bacterial vaginosis so for
this particular study the swab samples
were again taken but instead of the
bacterial vaginosis away they run on V
which are now flora away so three
samples were taken which were GV
positive but the aim of the experiment
is to look at the profiling indication
of these three samples amongst them and
also between the different pathogens
itself so if you look at the plate over
here this one well performs oh this one
girl includes the bacteria of the
interest associated with vagina flora
and the last side wells would include
the controls and in this one plate one
sample can be tested so the 3g be
positive samples were taken the DNA was
extracted mixed with the microbial qpcr
mastermix put it on the pc are played
run on the real-time pcr machine
then a profiling experiment analysis was
performed after giving the analysis we
received a detail for profiling of all
the 3g be positive samples and the
associations are made and shown in the
graph over here so each one of the on
the x-axis are the different bacteria
associated with vagina flora and each of
these little bar associated with the
bacteria are the three samples and
another interesting point that the
collaborators associated are in the
samples with the high junior pendants
there was an increase in co-op rents or
BD associated microorganisms and
decrease in abundance of normal flora
for the lactobacillus Chris Prentiss so
this has led to another round of
research to really understand the
associations between different bacteria
in different applications so with this
what will the common themes in these
experiments how to best carry out these
focus metagenomic studies so each case
has a user profiling a distinct set of
genes or species and experiments can be
easily translated to large multi factor
experiments and also you could test
range of sample sites and you a
quantitative and qualitative data
generation so moving forward how do we
really design these asses for the
microbial study now as I mentioned
before it is really important to
understand the 16s rrna region as we
fill a genetic marker for bacterial IT
so at hydrogen what was done all the
sequences were taken from the taxonomic
classified by green jeans taxonomy
where we took the fairly specific group
and Freddie specific primer combine them
together to get a very specific asset
for this if you would like to do a
homebrew method or all the data that
will perform to optimize and validate
and to create these asses we started
with the sensitivity experiment the
deletion seen the generation series
testing for pcr efficiency and
sensitivity were performed so each of
the asset each of the sequence each of
the taqman probe sequences that were
created were tested in terms of their
target copy numbers so they run on the
real-time pcr machine to see the lowest
limit of detection the lowest limit of
quantification and also a linear range
of standard curve was drafted to see if
the range is linear or not with this you
can determine the sensitive senses
sensitivity of a microbial assay in two
terms the allergy that is the limit of
detection it is the lower lowest amount
of analyte DNA molecule in a sample that
is able to be distinguished from sample
that contains no analyte so often the
LOD is reported as colony forming units
and then the le look you which is the
lower limit of quantitation is the
lowest amount of analyte that can be
distinguished from a sample with another
amount of analyte often reported as gene
copies since colonies may contain
multiple copies of a gene so any review
is is actually useful for quantitation
because it states the limit at which two
samples can be quantified as opposed to
simple qualification so in terms of
hygiene statement we have used the ll of
Q to determine the sensitivity of each
of the assays and we put it in terms of
the number of copy of G
but this is these are the methods that
you would use to determine the
sensitivity of any of the microbial
assay that you create homebrew or you
have taken from chi jet plane oh then
the next very important step for the
validation of the asses are for
specificity to determine the specificity
of the microbial DNA qpcr acid to
determine this specificity the first
step is to create the to create the
sequences against the 16s rrna region
excuse me excuse me oh yes so they
determine the specificity first you will
have to create the sequence against the
16s order the neg region in terms of
bacteria or any other region in terms of
different species and then you will have
to test bioinformatic me which is the
best target hit once you have determined
it you can create this lady sequences
which you would like to test in the lab
when she tested the Lark the way you
would proceed is to test it against the
genomic DNA from different bacteria and
fungi to ensure there are no
cross-reactivity so in terms for
collagen what we did we tested against
with 119 genomic DNA which we got from
atcc and then they were put in different
pools and around ten poles were made and
each essay were tested against different
points each for did not contain the DNA
from the same genus to facilitate the
identification of any cross-reacting
species and each will contain equivalent
to two thousand journal copies for each
microbial species
in addition which I say was tested
against human moms and right genomic DNA
so it is really important as when we
research through a lot of researchers
were also creating the pool and testing
it against the genomic DNA but each of
the assays were not tested more than ten
genomic DNA but at Canton we took and we
tested it against 119 genomic DNA just
to ensure that we are getting the best
specificity and there no
cross-reactivity between the two species
so these were the pool that worker that
were created so for example if we take
the example of the calculor factor each
mccampbell of actor actually was tested
against the pool one till the pool 11
and the other species of campylobacter
were present in different pools you
check if they were getting cross he
acted or not so once this is done
another set of experiments that will
perform and then can be performed for
the assay validation are to do the spike
in recovery experiment to check for the
specificity in a complex background and
this is one of the class how it looked
Phil spike in recovery when it was done
on all the experiments on all the assets
that are offered by kaijin then another
set of experiments or that can be
performed or to check for the assay
validation is to compare the results
with NGS so what the rmv scientists at
high dented they took the same sample
the swap the vaginal flora swab sample
and the tested it against the qpcr of
array throughout the vagina power and
also the tested and perform the whole
genome sequencing for NGS so over there
when we looked at the data we took four
samples and the data for the vagina
flora qpcr and NGS are right here and
all these graphs
which showed confidence to each other so
they were very similar results and with
this we concluded that since both the
NGS I the qpcr technology are sewing
showing similar results it's better to
proceed with the qpcr technology as the
data output is really simple and I
pageant we provide the complete insight
in terms of providing complementary data
analysis for these particular qpcr
arrays and asses and also with the qpcr
technology the hands-on time is really
less that is less than four hours and
also the procedure is really simple so
if you would like to do an analysis at
the species level it is recommended to
proceed with the qpcr technology against
the NGS so what are the solutions for
identification and profiling from kaijin
as I mentioned before for the bacteria
region the 16s rrna region is really
important what I kaijin what may have
done we have used the document probe
technology and we have created the
primers and probes against this n 16s
rrna region and with this we created the
three C's for the product that is the
content custom and control and how I
define all of these are for the content
we have the largest microbiome portfolio
that is we have experimental iver ified
580 asses and when I say experimenta
verified that means we had considered by
informatica Lee and also we have gone
through extensive lab verification in
terms of determining these specificity
sensitivity and performance for all
these assays and we have more than 580
acids and when I say assays I mean each
species whether it is bacteria fungi
whether it is jeans that is antibiotic
resistant genes valence factors etc the
second point here is the customization
so not only we have supplied the
catalogue assays and erased but also we
provide researcher and ability to custom
their product so you can select from
eight to 384 microbial species for
simultaneous detection and profiling so
from the list of 580 asses you can
select up to 384 microbial species or
antibiotic resistant genes are various
factors and you can select any layout
you would like put it on the plane and
test it for yourself and design your
research focused experiments with this
we have ensured that the cost for the
customization and the catalog are not
much different so then we give full
freedom to the researcher if you do not
know which microbes you would like to
test for a particular application come
back to us we will help you if you
already know which microbes you want to
focus select it let us know we will pre
spot it on a plate and give it to you
for your research the third C is the
control we have insured and we have we
have developed integrated controls with
ensure reliability of results in terms
of positive template PPC and bacterial
and fungal that a specialist Canada etc
we also have really high sensitivity
that is all the acids most of the asses
can detect as low as 10 copy numbers and
all the data is available if you are in
if the researcher is interested so
looking forward what it can do it you
can using this asses and away you can
perform to kind of experiment 1 is the
profiling and the other is the
identification with identification you
will get the answer of yes or no if this
particular microbe is present in your
sample or if it does not
the new sample with profiling which is
also known as any quantification you can
compare the amount of microbe or ginge
microbial species or genes change
between the two samples and between and
make association in the microbial
species itself and the answers are sold
change and also if you would like to do
absolute quantification then you can
take the highest concentrated positive
control dialed in and create a standard
curve to check the number of copies of
genes with each micro to do the absolute
quantification this is the complete
sample to incite workflow from hydrogen
so we have DNA isolation that for the
sample extraction the asses and erased
for the downswing application and then
the data analysis we have the
complementary gene block data analysis
and along with this you can either do
the complete process manually or you can
use our automation systems depending on
the number of samples you can either use
kayak you've got you HT guy a symphony
and then move further with high agility
to determine the integrity of the DNA or
RNA you're working with and loaded Inc
you for the real-time pcr and then we
gene blow for the data analysis center
so the NGS workflow we offer various
kids in terms of sample disruption
sample preparation NGS library
progression and year software and
validation by qpcr for the NGS library
preparation you can also use our assay
kits for QC testing that is to detect
species specific genomic DNA and hosts
and or specific genomic DNA and my true
blue genomic microbial DNA so you can
take our asses for bacterial and fungal
which will determine the total count of
microbial DNA and also you can take our
asses for human genomic DNA or mom's
genomic DNA etc but whatever species
you're working with and then calculate
the
sure in terms of horse DNA vs the
microbial DNA to determine the quality
of the sample to ensure if you would
like to proceed with the NGS run or not
once you have done the discovery phase
with the NGS you can also use our gala t
you can use our Q pcr assays and arrays
to validate your data and we can always
create the custom asses for your
particular sequence that you have found
through the NGS to ditch in mind and to
use it for various other application and
purposes for your research studies so
this in short is the complete workflow
and the complete portfolio for the
microbial qpcr you can start with any
sample site that is to tissue vagina
fluid daily vegetables etc so any
complex metabolic sample you can start
with then you can use the microbial DNA
extraction kids from kaijin we have
seven dedicated kit for extraction
depending on which sample type you are
using and then all the downstream
application of the asses and the arrays
are validated or any qpcr instrument so
if you have a rotating queue or if you
have a bio right ABI any of these
machines with a 96 or a 384 or 100 well
you all of these protocols for the asses
and arrays are optimized and provided in
behind Boone then we have the product in
249 one is the two format that is the
asses each of the bacterial or the
microbial species or the antibiotic
resistant genes come in the tube and it
can be tested for either 20 in terms of
a circuits and 100 samples in terms of
assets on the other are the erase the
arrays are the application based focus
that is it is focusing any particular
application and all the microbial
species on the plate are associated with
that particular application and then the
next is the custom array which is used
anywhere from eight to 384 species or
change with the controls and let us know
with the instrument you have we will pre
spot it on the plate and give it back to
you for your analysis so when we are
talking about the qpcr assays as I
mentioned we have 580 total assays and
it is divided in types of microbes that
is bacteria fungi virus finest fights
etc and it is also divided in / body
site application that is airway blood
God oral skin urogenital etc so these
are these five women etq pcr assays are
also divided and wasn't a popular essay
by industry for example for beer
spoilage you have lactobacillus make
espero etc for women health we have
candida micro plasma trichomonas etc so
that is why if you have in popular
application and you would like to plan
us the study with us please let us know
and we would be very happy to help you
out with it then moving further we have
16 catalogue qpcr application-based qpcr
arrays for women health we have a
channel for bacterial vaginosis for
infectious diseases we have a spirit
reinfection intestinal infection sepsis
urinary tract infection for hospital
research we have oral disease metabolic
disorder antibiotic resistance genes
again if you would like to know which
microbes are associated with all these
panels feel free to ask us for the list
for the food and wet industry we have
different testing food test testing
raised for meat seafood daily protein
vegetables etc and some of our popular
arrays are metabolic disorder for gut
research and dividing resistant genes
but now bacterial vaginosis and we also
have a race for water analysis and by
defense so this is how a typical 96-well
plate would look 90 of these would be
your species and the last fight would be
different controls are associated with
that plate so we have the host assays
that detect
DNA to test the sample collection we
have fun bacteria and panned a
specialist and kind of dark to detect
the presence of fungal RNA or the total
bacterial count and then we have a PVC
which is the positive pcr control
reaction that test at the PCR reaction
film focus PCR inhibitors from the
sample these come in different formats
of its sample1 sample2 with four samples
with eight samples and it also for the
custom away you can we have some of the
layers that we have already specified
but we can also work around any layout
that the customer might be interested in
so to summarize our we do have some
updated ivd customers using our
intestinal panel of our respiratory
panel and also our women health panel of
these are the individual asses and these
are all accredited or and are used by
after dated ivt customers and to give a
glance of rehab a complimentary tune
called chain broke at charging calm and
where oh where the you can start with
different tools such as browse by
research area browse by biology etc and
you can find the right products for your
application so please try to visit the
wwe.com where you can access get access
to all the complimentary tools that are
available to make your research really
easy and helpful in terms of microbial
qpcr NGS all the other product lines
also from Titan to summarize we define
the microbiome and the key role it plays
in human health very the knee and
methods for rapid detection of microbial
species we discussed the focus
metagenomic studies I introduce the
microbial DNA qpcr as a pipeline
which is the largest collection of
microbial ID assays available and
available in radius product formats to
simplify experiments we have the custom
arrays and assays and you can also use
for validation and QC for NGS workflow
so with this thank you so much and now I
will hand it back over to Brenda or for
any questions thank you an Asia for that
informative presentation before we get
started on the question and answer
session I'd like to remind our audience
how to submit their questions you can
submit questions by typing them in the
green human a box which can be found by
clicking on the green human a button at
the lower left of the presentation
window and we'll try to get to as many
of your questions as we can and our
first question what is the difference
between positive pcr control PPC and
microbial DNA positive control a good
question because tiger Brenda it is a
really good question of the difference
between the PPC that is the pc a
positive control and the microbial
positive template is on the pc a
positive control ensures in the PCR that
you put together work or not and it also
takes into account about any innovators
that might be coming from the microbial
samples but for the positive pcr
template they are the Metro build
positive template that is the only goal
of each of the asses that heightened
phosphorus which is which is used on the
PCR play to ensure if the particular
plot at the particular assay that the
researcher is lessened won't or not
so back to render thank you free answer
we have another question are the essays
species-specific thanks Brenda yes Oh
most of the assays ask me she's a
specific and their specific to a
particular species such as bacteria
fungi too deep to the microbes such as a
bacteria fungi viruses etc and they're
also specific within them so it would be
specific to for example or trichomonas
gb a particular species of candida and
if some of the assets may detect other
species but all the information is
available on the website as well as on
the asset list that what is the
sensitivity of each of these assets and
also the specificity for each of these
assets and what it depends on what it
made it it and also all these results
have been pleased with the help of
bioinformatics research and also doing
extensive nod verification nice dr.
Brenda our next question what are the
minimum sample requirements for
microbial DNA to pcr kips so the minimum
central requirement our depends on what
assays are erased the customers are
using so if you are using an asset kit
then and using a 96-well plate then you
can use five nanogram per sample if
you're using a 384-well plate then you
can use to nanogram per sample if you
are taking it from the meta-genome
example but if you're taking it out from
the cell culture then
you can just reduce it fifty percent and
for the complete plate for a 96-well
plate it is approximately 500 milligram
for the 96-well plate and if you're
taking it from a metagenomic sample and
it is around 2 15 anagram for the
384-well plate if you are taking a dart
from the meta-genome example and again
for the samples from the culture you can
just reduce it to half and use those
samples for different applications
depending on which kit you are using
activator our next question are the
microbial DNA qpcr essays wet lab
verified thank you yes on the owner or
language verified first they are
determined by and somatically by during
a hit method for getting the sequences
against the 16s rrna division and then
they are taken by chi-chi and there they
are lab verified in terms of doing
extensive research on these sensitivity
specificity and determining all the
other factors around the assays and then
before right before it's shipped out to
the customer it's again QC since the
microbial contamination is really
notorious so it's really important for
hydrogen to maintain the quality control
so everything all the complete portfolio
is not verified as well as by informatik
lee verified
thank you our next question how can i
calculate the number of bacterial cells
that are present in a sample using a
microbial DNA qpcr essays also yes oh so
you can calculate of the bacterial
counts by calculating the standard curve
you can each of the positive template or
that we provide that is the only go for
the microbial qpcr assay is 2000 copy
numbers you can plot a standard curve
and they might the number of cells for
each of the of of the microbial assays
great we have time for one more question
a question is how can we identify mixed
sequences generated from the microbial
sample so if you have extracted DNA from
the microbial sample and you're looking
for a species specific solution then you
can buy the species-specific hace and it
will determine that particular assay in
your metabolic sample now what is more
important is what species it is rather
than which sequence you have extracted
from that particular sample if you are
starting with next-generation sequencing
and you have a specific sequence that
you do not know the species for then we
can always create a custom asset for
that particular sequence and you can use
it for different applications and
experimental designs doctor thank you
that's all the time we have for
questions today I'd like to thank Anisha
car here for her informative
presentation and also of course thank
our sponsor cryogen in making today's
educational webcast possible today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through februari of 2016 you'll
receive an email from laverton you in
this webcast will be available for
replay we invite you to forward that
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event thank you
for joining us see you next time goodbye